hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over what
i consider to be the saddest death in
all of tokyo revenges i honestly never
expected something this traumatizing to
actually happen especially after emma's
death back in the tenjiku arc this here
is the death of the vice captain of the
tokyo manji gang ken ryoguji better
known as everyone's favorite character
drakken but if you'd like to reminisce
and remember draken along with all of
the past fallen tokyo avengers
characters long after their deaths then
be sure to check out otaku lamps today's
video sponsor and your source for
officially licensed anime leds partnered
with crunchyroll funimation and over 20
anime studios otaku lamps makes cool
official merch that you know comes
straight from the source they even work
directly with kodacha and the anime
studios for tokyo avengers each lamp can
change between 16 colors using the
included remote and has a bunch of other
features as well imagine having mikey
draken or the entire gang lit up on your
desk or bookshelf right next to your
manga collection they even have more
characters and designs dropping with the
upcoming weeks like berserk so make sure
to check out otaku lamps for the
upcoming holidays you can only get these
at otakulams.com so make sure to use
code diavolo and get 10 off with your
order as well the link i'll leave down
in the description for you guys also
just want to thank them for sponsoring
this video but anyway enough of that
let's get into the most heart-wrenching
death so far in an already heartbreaking
story so i think the best place to start
this is just before the commotion all
goes down at the amusement park after a
long day out we'll send you and a
quickly approaching night just before
going to sleep takamichi is suddenly
disturbed by the sound of a rock tapping
on his window after walking over to the
window takamichi finds senju standing
outside in her brahman uniform asking if
takamichi wanted to go out on a date
with her after takamichi accepts they
both head off and arrive at an amusement
park in which senju states that she's
been wanting to come here for a while as
she hasn't been here since the sixth
grade after they ride a bunch of
different rides around the amusement
park they make their way to the roller
coaster as they are waiting for their
ride to start senju tells takamichi that
both him and dracon will be the ones to
handle the kanto majin gang during the
battle of the three deities on the 14th
of july while she and takomi will take
care of the rokuharatandai before
takamichi can even reply sinju states
that she can even handle all of this
herself and that once mikey and south
are defeated she wants to be number one
as the ride takes off and takamichi
screams in fear sends you notes that
takomi has changed he's not the same as
he used to be as his goals for the
growth of brahmin have changed he wants
the gangs to become bigger but senju
states that if more people get involved
in the gang some of them will be
unsatisfiable and it will result in
conflict she says that instead of
growing right now firstly they need to
defeat the opposing gangs in the
upcoming battle after the right ends and
they get off senju notices people
writing and hanging tanzaku on bamboo
trees while singing senju tells
takamichi that they are both going to
make a wish after writing their wishes
senju laughs at him and tells takamichi
that his wish of defeating maiki kun is
boring takamichi nervously tells her to
be quiet as he was just writing his
current goals senju then writes her wish
and shows takamichi while she's laughing
it is revealed that her wish is to
protect takamichi standing there stunned
takamichi thinks to himself that she's
such a straight-up person and as he
thinks this senji says with a smile on
her face that she's never done anything
like this before and asks takamichi if
they can become friends of course
takamichi instantly replies with yes and
reaches out his hand to shake hers
telling her that if anything happens to
her as well he will definitely protect
her suddenly as their hands connect
takamichi's mind flashes and he begins
to see images of a wounded senju lying
on the ground while screaming out her
name and thinking to himself that again
he's seeing these random visions send
you mata's four words i fulfilled my
promise
again all of a sudden just as quickly as
they came his visions disappeared but
takamichi is left stumped thinking about
an amusement park and the fact that this
time his visions were much clearer than
previously
justice senji notes that the rain has
started it flashes away from the duo and
instead we see draken standing outside
of the dnd motor shop noting the
changing weather just as it begins to
pour down with rain and you pay pulls
upside draken who tells them that as
they speak the guys from the roku heart
italian diet are heading towards
takamichi again we skip back over to
takamichi who's just realized that the
place senju suffers a possibly
life-altering wound is here at the
amusement park as sensu runs away
pulling up her hoodie to stop the rain
takamichi confirms to himself that
indeed it is not the distant future but
today this moment happens in a cafe
senju and takamichi sit and decide to
wait out the rain while there sinju
tells takamichi that she has to go to
the bathroom and then quickly heads off
to do so meanwhile takamichi is lost in
his thoughts pondering what to do in
case of his future visions he recalls
his vision featuring senju bleeding from
the head and dying remembering that
sinji was in the restroom he rushes off
to find her scolding himself for leaving
her alone just as he reaches the
restroom takamichi sees the tanzaku with
senju's promise to protect him as he
comes to a sudden realization a group of
hooded masked men approach him much to
takamichi's surprise they are actually
targeting him one of the men asks
another if he is sure about his actions
in response the other man reassures him
reminding him that their actions will
help them and prove their status yet
another man protests stating that they
have already consulted south however the
man pulls out a gun responding that
south will understand his actions as he
stares at the barrel of the gun
takamichi pieces together the meaning of
his vision
senju will die trying to protect him
suddenly behind him senju rushes up but
takamichi cautions her to stay back as
the man clutches the gun warning
takamichi not to move senju screams for
him to stop but takamichi runs towards
senju telling her not to come near him
as he tackles her to the ground the man
fires the gun with takamichi lying atop
sinju the gunman thinks he successfully
killed takamichi and chuckles to himself
however takamichi rises unscathed as
senji looks up at him in surprise
takamishi asks if she is alright telling
her that he cannot let her die
the man curses wondering how he missed
takamichi braces for the bullet that is
about to fire but is surprised when the
gun classes onto the ground turning he
sees draken who has just knocked out the
man holding the gun
as dracon ensures takamichi's safety
takamishi's stammers and relief and
surprise
while the commotion at the amusement
park is taking place mikey overlooks the
city behind him koku asks what the
matter is maki replies that it is
raining and he has a bad feeling about
the night meanwhile the noise of the
gunshot scares away the crowd at the
sight of draken the men from the
rokuharatandai flee in absolute terror
still shocked at draken's sudden arrival
takamichi thanks him for saving him as
he kicks away the gun draken remarks on
the brazen dangerousness of takamichi's
attackers after takamichi confirms that
senju is unharmed takamichi asks why
draken showed up and drakken explains
that inyupay heard that the
rokuharatandai was targeting takamichi
as takamichi remarks surprise at his
targeting by the roku harder draken
smiles reminding him of his revered
status in the delinquent world growing
serious draken adds that the conflict
between the three deities may not be as
simple as a delinquent conflict he
explains that the gangs are involved
with unethical businesses which invest
in the gangs after takamichi wonders
aloud about the future drakken eerily
speculates that mikey predicted this
takamichi confides in dracon telling him
that he can foresee future events he
explains his vision of senju dying and
begins to thank draken for helping him
change the future events smiling draken
says that he is glad suddenly century
reminds them that they need to leave the
premises as they may get in trouble if
found by more rokuhara members or the
police as takamichi runs behind senju he
notices draken is still standing
not moving with his back turned away
from him
abruptly draken tells takamichi to relay
a message to mikey he tells him
don't cause too much trouble
confused tsakamishi tells draken to tell
mikey himself but before takamichi can
finish his sentence draken collapses and
falls to the ground having sustained
three gunshot wounds he says he has done
all that he can do when draken comes to
he notes his inability to hear move or
see clearly finding a frantic takamichi
over him takamichi informs dracon that
he is called an ambulance and senju is
looking for help he tries reassuring
draken with his smile but draken notices
takamichi's clenched fist aloud draken
realizes he is dying upon hearing draken
say that he realizes he is dying
takamichi tears up he insists that he
will be fired by tomorrow asking for
draken's affirmation and reassurance
however draken steers into the rainy sky
as he prepares himself for the impending
death with a faint grin draken tells
takamichi not to blame himself he
explains his decisions to protect
takamichi was one of his own and not a
consequence of takamichi's time leap
because takamichi had already saved his
life drakken says that in return he was
happy to sacrifice his after reassuring
takamichi understands this dracon
reminisces on his elementary school days
where he would lose many fights against
older kids much to the surprise of
takamichi following his defeat draken
would crawl on the ground and look up
towards the sky
similar to his current state looking
into the sky grounded him and provided
peace
wiping his tears takamichi says that he
understands that feeling however draken
adds that mikey has never seen the sky
as mikey has never been defeated noting
that that is a shame
with his words growing more and more
strained dracon explains his admiration
of mikey's strength as he carried and
endured all of his hardships for his
friends and all of tomen choking on his
blood dracon says that he wishes he
could help mikey even more and asks
takamichi to do one more favor one that
he considers lame with tears in his eyes
draken asks takamichi to take care of
mikey and takamichi promises to do so
after the ambulance arrives the
paramedics begin to load draken into the
ambulance while this is happening
drakken starts to think back to january
the 1st 2005 before takamichi had joined
the group during this flashback thomas
leaders all ride towards the beach to
celebrate the new year draken asks
spaghi and the rest of the main tomen
crew about their respective gang
conflicts both of which ended in tomen's
victory
meanwhile payan parchin hakai and
mitsuya attribute tomen's success to
mikey's leadership drakken agrees adding
that mikey who is riding ahead of him is
the face of tomen watching mikey matsuya
remarks that without mikey's presence it
feels lonely interrupting their thoughts
mikey urges them to ride faster as they
may miss the sunrise the entire group
arrives at the beach at 4 a.m where they
marvel at the beautiful starry sky due
to the cold weather bhaji orders shifuyu
and hikai to shoot to the shop and buy
something to warm the group up in the
meantime draken starts running around on
the beach to warm up joined by mitsuya
baji parchin payan and smiley while
running around they joke about the fifth
division's leader's absence and how
mucho did not want to bring his car out
and that he does not ride a bike because
of his age by the time hikai and shifuyu
return from the store the sky has
brightened and the captains have warmed
up and tired out from the run draken
spots mikey at the end of the pier
watching the sunrise as draken
approaches mikey's spot the other
members stare in oar at the beautiful
sky as the sun begins to break through
the dark cold night mikey places his
palm above the sun and clenches it
grasping the sun he tells dracon to hold
on to the world
grinning dracon agrees that this year
they will conquer the whole country as
he remembers that morning draken breaks
down and weeps remarking that his final
memories are with all of his best
friends and the previous members of
tomen
as he cries lying on the concrete and
the cold rain he tells emma that he is
on his way visualizing his spirit as it
leaves his body to reunite with his one
and only true love emma
flashing away from the amusement park
roku heart of
top executives watches south beats the
life out of the perpetrators of draken's
death although south beats the men for
their extreme actions he also grins
adding that they did extremely well
back at the park senju watches as
takamichi stares off into the distance
in shock as if he has lost his entire
will for everything he has done so far
takamichi recalls the moments prior as
he frantically asks the paramedic of
draken's condition
they then give him the cold news that
draken has truly passed away and they
are no longer able to resuscitate him
senju screams out his name several times
but to no gain as she fails to rouse him
out of his catatonic state confirming
the collapse of thaiman's most beloved
member
just then akashi arrives behind them
after confirming that the roku heart of
tiendai perpetrated draken's death he
swears revenge ordering binkai to gather
the rest of brahman hearing akashi's
plans senju is shocked saying that they
cannot act today
she and her brother begin arguing about
the best course of action with akai
angrily declaring that their goals have
changed from being number one to a
complete blood bath
senju angrily screams back at him trying
to stand her ground
all the while takamichi remains in his
state shaken to the core with a look
we've never seen from him before the
look of pure grief
all of a sudden we hear footsteps and
the arrival of tirano and with south
sudden ridicule of draken's death this
somewhat snaps takamichi out of his
distraught state after taunting draken's
death some more he and akashi throw
words at each other and begin to prepare
their gangs to battle
suddenly the distinct sound of a
motorcycle interrupts them both
turning his head akashi notices the
sound of shinichiro's cbt-250t
and to the absolute shock of everyone in
attendance a somber mikey arrives alone
at the scene
quietly a stunned takamichi shakily
utters his estranged friend's name
well sadly that brings us to the end of
draken's life honestly as i said at the
beginning of the video i really never
saw this coming it was something that i
actually felt like was impossible as
draconis already died countless times
throughout the past and it seemed like
takamichi had solidified his safety
through his actions
sadly we all had the blanket pulled over
our eyes and failed to see the small
signs that pointed towards dracon's
demise earlier on like this placement on
volume 4 of the manga which at face
value may seem harmless but when you
look into japanese superstition and the
history you realize that the number four
in japanese is one of these six unlucky
numbers traditionally number four is
unlucky because it is sometimes
pronounced as she which is the word for
death in japanese or something else we
must again on chapter 204 where draken
is featured alongside shinichiro baji
and emma and a panel just before mikey
jumps to what he thought was his death
these small things may seem silly to
speculate at the time but as we can see
here maybe this was all actually
predetermined and had been for a while
but anyway i do hope you all enjoyed the
video as i really enjoyed making this
video on draken as he is one of my top
three tokyo adventures characters and it
was heartbreaking to see him go so if
you have enjoyed the video and want to
keep up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content and just more anime
content in general then make sure you
hit the subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people also i just want to thank
otaku lamps again for sponsoring this
video and remember to use code diavolo
for 10 percent off at the checkout but
anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate dear volume and
i'll see you all in april
bye
[Music]